my name is dr kate bieberdorf but you
may know me as kate the chemist today
i'll be answering your questions from
twitter this is chemistry support
[Music]
sci rehab wants to know isn't the whole
universe a chemical reaction
yes
absolutely 100 yes chemistry is
everywhere in everything if you can see
it breathe it touch it it's chemistry
we're taking atoms and rearranging them
into different ways and it's just
chemistry everywhere everything
everything around us it's elemental next
up from enon yam wants to know chemistry
lecture why does diet coke and mentos
make a chemical reaction mentos is a
porous candy and so if you look really
closely at a mentos mento mentos all of
it on the outside has these little holes
there's these little pores and when we
drop it into diet coke that is
immediately attractive to carbon dioxide
so all the carbon dioxide in the soda
rushes to the to the candy and it starts
to like sit on those pores but it's not
just one carbon dioxide molecule or a
second carbon dioxide molecule it's
hundreds and thousands of them slamming
together at once so as they reach the
candy they're smashing into each other
here they build up pressure and they end
up shooting straight out of the diet
coke and so we have this really
beautiful soda volcano it has nothing to
do with the diet coke itself it's the
fact that there's carbon dioxide in the
soda and it's the shape of the candy
itself so you could do this experiment
with coke with mountain dew with any
soda you want it just so happens that
diet coke works really well and it
doesn't contain the sugar so it's much
easier to clean up now holly gene05
wants to know in chemistry how do you
get two bonds to break up this feels
like a joke um
i will say you can get two bonds to
break um whenever you have
neighboring atoms that they are more
attracted to so let me give you an
example i don't know if you've ever
heard of this but blake lively and ryan
reynolds when they were first together
they were set up on blind dates with
other people and so you have blake and
another man with ryan and another woman
and so they're sitting across the table
from each other not interested in their
original pairing very interested in each
other and so this is referred to as a
double replacement reaction where you
start off partnered with somebody else
but then you see something that's better
a better option i mean it's ryan and
ultimately how can you you know and so
then you form another bond and so now
blake and ryan are now paired and then
these other two are not but in theory
they could be partnered up if they
wanted to so it's as simple as that your
atoms are more attracted to something
else kik the pj wants to know just found
out that my brain has chemicals inside
it wtf that doesn't sound good how do i
get them out of there
no
pj you want chemicals in your brain you
need them otherwise you're not going to
be able to function at all
for example adenosine is in your brain
and that helps you get sleepy or drowsy
so it encourages your body to go to
sleep you absolutely need these
molecules in your brain without them you
would not be a functioning human
courtney neros wants to know if atoms
are primarily composed of empty space
why can't you pass your hand through a
solid object so let's go to the basics
here an atom is formed with a nucleus in
the center and in the center you have
protons and neutrons so if my body was
an atom my kidneys my liver those would
be my protons and neutrons like inside
my core now on the outside of your atom
that's where your electrons are moving
around so that would be like my gloves
or you know my sunglasses or a hat
something on that's on the outside so
atoms can really easily exchange
electrons to a neighboring atom i can
give you my gloves i can give you my
scarf i can't really give you my kidney
or my liver that's going to be really
difficult so we can exchange electrons
but not so much protons and neutrons now
the question here is why can't you pass
your hand through a solid object and the
reason being is because that nucleus is
extraordinarily dense it's very very
dense it's got those neutrons those
protons and it takes up a lot of space
and so yes you can pass your hand
through the spot that has all the
electrons but as soon as you slam into
that nucleus that's a dense object that
you cannot pass through now we have
carly 0575 wants to know how do
pheromones work pheromones are so cool
so what happens is one animal let's say
you have an ant is going to release some
pheromones then a neighboring ant is
going to absorb those pheromones into
their body and all of a sudden have all
these new signals some information so
ants tell each other where food is
other animals could possibly give out
sex pheromones so it's kind of like a
way to play cupid and you can encourage
someone else to be attracted to you just
by giving those off
unfortunately humans don't have sex
pheromones because we learned how to
communicate so if we just wink and give
a little high five
usually that can send the message across
we don't need to like shove our hormones
into someone else to make them attracted
to us iq air wants to know what's in a
firework it's a combination of potassium
nitrate some carbon and some sulfur so
essentially what happens is the
potassium nitrate decomposes releasing
oxygen gas when oxygen is in the
presence of charcoal or carbon it's
going to burn and the sulfur helps to
create a lot of smoke now there's
usually a second piece in there like a
delayed timer that's going on as well
and so once that gets hot enough that's
gonna do the second boom so the first
explosion gets us all the way up to the
sky and the second explosion gives us
the huge bang now this is where we see
the colors so if there's red there's
going to be some strontium in there if
there's some green or blue there's
probably copper the pinks are from
potassium those burnt orange beautiful
colors those are from sodium so it's a
big mixture of molecules and it's all
thanks to chemistry okay next one saint
gregory wants to know does anybody even
know what electrolytes actually are or
do i know electrolytes are charged
minerals so they're cations and anions
in the human body so often we see things
like sodium calcium magnesium maybe some
chlorine and they all make sure that
your body functions properly so they're
in charge of sending nerve signals
signals through your body they're in
charge of making sure your heart beats
some of them make sure that you have
enough fluid inside the cells while
another one makes sure that you have
enough fluid outside of the cells the
chlorine is even
used to help digest things in your
stomach so it's all over your body and
you need these electrolytes and that's
why if you're drinking alcohol you
usually feel like awful the next day
because you've pushed all these
electrolytes out of your body and now
your body's a little bit wonky all right
from sciamerica what's the chemistry
behind home pregnancy tests oh this is a
great question home pregnancy tests work
very similarly to our rapid covid test
so you have a piece of paper and you
have an antibody that's essentially sewn
into the paper so when a woman becomes
pregnant about 10 days after conception
we have this hormone called hcg and what
happens is you can urinate that out onto
your test and if that hormone is present
in the urine it will bind to the
antibody in the test and it will
activate a dye molecule and so that's
where you'll see that like blue plus
sign or the blue word pregnant or
anything like that fun fact like a long
time ago in ancient egypt they used to
use home pregnancy tests by having women
urinate on barley seeds and wheat seeds
and if they sprouted really quickly that
hormone must be present in the woman
because that's what activated those
seeds and make them sprout really
quickly so they could actually detect
pregnancy with about 70 to 85 percent
accuracy up next af stampton asks what
is the most dangerous chemical reaction
okay so you have to be careful because
this question would absolutely start a
fight with a gigantic group of nerds
it's like asking you which is the best
superhero um in general i would say
anything with lots of nitrogens so if we
have lots of nitrogens that usually
means explosion so there's things called
azines um there's one called a zyto
azide azine so c2n14
and that one kind of has the internet's
reputation of being the most explosive
it's not really but it's very unstable
and that's why it gets this reputation
one thing could be it would it would
explode if you stir it it would explode
if you heat it up it can also explode
when you're not even in the room i will
never forget when my professor was
talking about these explosive materials
and he said in his lab a friend of his
picked up a beaker and just like not
thinking about it picked up his safety
glasses to wipe his brow and right as
the safety glasses went up the thing
just exploded the guy no longer can see
and i have vividly remembered that and i
am unbelievably anal about my goggles
now
bitter mode on
asks who created the periodic table it
depends who you're asking the very first
version of the periodic table was a man
who brought three elements together and
just put them together based on
explosiveness the second guy came
through and took these little sets of
three and made triads and made little
like teas with them into little x's but
at that point we had to memorize all
these t's and it was really complicated
so two men at the exact same time but
separately individually so dimitri
mendeleev and then lothar mayar came
together and they organized all of our
elements based on increasing atomic mass
but here's why dimitri mendeleev always
gets the credit he noticed a pattern so
let's say we had a pattern like 2 4 8
10. there's that missing number six so
we would see that it would go okay 2 4 6
8 ten and mendel did the exact same
thing he was like there are two elements
that we are definitely missing he saw
the pattern and left holes for that in
the periodic table so ten years later
when gallium and germanium were
discovered mendelev was given all the
credit for the periodic table because
not only did he order it in increasing
atomic mass but he also predicted these
unknown elements pretty cool right
next up from st mary tulsa why does
popcorn pop how does a lava lamp work
and how do you make slime popcorn
kernels have a little piece of water in
there so a couple water molecules in the
liquid state now when we heat them up
the liquid water converts to gaseous
water so it vaporizes but the gas takes
up space and it moves around so it's
slamming against the side of the kernel
and eventually when it has a high enough
velocity or enough kinetic energy it
actually pushes that kernel to pop and
now you made popcorn
for a lava lamp equally cool what we
have is some kind of container that has
usually oil on top and then liquid at
bottom
and then what you need to do is somehow
generate some gas
a simple way of doing this would be to
add like an alka-seltzer tablet which
would generate carbon dioxide and so the
gas forms at the bottom of the lava lamp
and it starts to pull up as it goes up
it kind of drags the water molecules
with it and they go all the way up to
the top so visually we see the water
molecules move through the oil layer
they get to the top the gas pops it lets
go of the water molecule water's more
dense than oil so it sinks down to the
bottom and then the process just repeats
itself carbon dioxide goes up it pops
water comes back down over and over
again very beautiful
last one how do you make slime fantastic
question let me show you you'll need
about one cup of glue three cups of
shaving cream so now we're gonna stir
stir stir
after that we're gonna add one teaspoon
of baking soda again stir stir so if
you're adding glitter or food coloring
now go to town so we're looking for a
nice homogeneous mixture so it's all
really mixed together two tablespoons of
contact solution is going to activate
your slime because we're adding boron
let this sit for like i don't know 30
minutes or so and let that reaction
happen but if you can't wait like me i
can't ever wait stick your hands right
in there
next up from cwpslv
so how exactly does chlorine work to
disinfect your pool water so what we
usually use is a hypochlorite
hypochlorous acid buffer it is a buffer
or a solution that locks the ph into
7.52
so what happens is if you add something
that's slightly acidic the basic
component of the buffer reaches out and
eats that neutralizes it keeps the pool
clean if you add something that's
slightly basic the acidic part of the
buffer will reach out and eat that and
keep the pool nice and clean next jack
of speed what is the difference between
evaporation and boiling hashtag
chemistry question are you one of my
students because this is an exam
question i use every year um so
evaporation and boiling are similar but
they're different so boiling happens at
a very specific temperature so here on
earth at atmospheric pressure
water is going to boil at 100 degrees
celsius or 212 degrees fahrenheit but
that is always going to happen at that
specific temperature evaporation can
happen anytime and so what happens is
you have all these water molecules let's
just assume you have a glass of water
you have all these water molecules and
they are moving at a distribution of
velocities so the ones that have really
high velocities really high kinetic
energy they have enough movement enough
wiggle around to actually like break
those hydrogen bonds break those
intermolecular forces and move from the
liquid state to the gas state but that
can happen at any temperature it does
not need to be 100 degrees celsius for
your glass of water to evaporate on your
nightstand next up nose nose nose how
does tomato juice make skunk smell go
away
it doesn't that's an old wives tale so
what happens is you actually have what's
referred to as olfactory fatigue and so
your brain just kind of stops smelling
the skunk smell and you're only smelling
the tomato smell so it's basically nose
blindness that's all next up g tesh21
how do fireflies glow fireflies have
this molecule in their abdomen called
luciferin and what happens is they're
able to essentially bring oxygen into
their bodies through all these little
holes and tubular pathways in their
bodies and once the oxygen hits that
molecule it reacts with a bioluminescent
enzyme that makes this thing glow it's
very beautiful
all right that's it i've gone through
all the questions i hope you've learned
something until next time